first let's build up the conceptual
mechanics for these new types of random
algorithms which accept some input n and
if n is prime our algorithm will output
prime with 100% certainty and it will
never label it as composite
however if n is composite then there
will be some tiny chance of error e that
it will label it prime otherwise there
is a one - this tiny error probability
that it will correctly identify it as
composite so we'll start simple out of
some universe of integers up to some
limit we grab a number and call this
integer N and we input n into our
machine and previously in our trial
division methods we basically iterated
through all values from 1 to the square
root of N and test it if that number
divides in and ideally we only wanted to
check Prime's to save time and if yes a
divides n then we know that N is a
composite number because we found a
composite witness if not then we aren't
sure so we go back and we increment a
and we test again and once we exhausted
all possible tests we could then say yes
and is prime if we found no divisors but
now let's be lazy what if we just pick a
few random integers and do a few
divisibility tests which you can think
of as random questions since we know
that some number n if its composite it
must have some divisors scattered around
and at minimum it has a single divisor
and some composite numbers have many
divisors so anyway we pick a random
integer a between 1 and the square root
of N and that's it then we just check if
a divides n and as before if a divides n
then we know for sure that n is
composite we found a witness if not then
we haven't learned too much except that
it could be prime so to be safe we could
generate a few more random a's and keep
testing and perhaps after a hundred or a
thousand iterations we could stop and
say it's probably prime with some
certainty say for example 99.9 percent
and this is similar to the example game
on conditional probability in the
simplest version we were trying to guess
if a coin was fair or if it was a
two-headed coin in this case tails is
like finding a divisor it's a witness of
a fair coin heads is the case where we
might want the person to flip again and
iterate in this case after around five
heads we are more than 90% sure so we
could stop and say oh we think the coin
is two-headed
so here is a program I've set up which
compares our old trial division methods
with this new random division test and
I'm specifically using the current trial
division speed leader which is a program
by Dino and I posted the link in the
header of the program so to begin notice
the variable number of trials this is
the number of random guesses so we'll
start at something small such as 3 and
notice even with small input if the
input is prime the random division
algorithm will always output prime but
when the input is composite we see the
random division can make mistakes and
identify it incorrectly as prime however
we can fix this by increasing the number
of trials and then the probability of an
error goes down and we see now that the
outputs more or less match
and as I test larger input the error
grows again so I need to increase the
number of random tests accordingly and
when I do the outputs match very nicely
they seem identical
but with huge input size I need
thousands of random tests for this to be
accurate so we haven't actually improved
the number of steps needed our trial
division method still seems better this
is because the error rate of the
division test is so high but we are
close we have the right idea so we need
to use another test we need an equation
which is fast to calculate that can be
used to prove whether a number is
composite and it must accept not only
the input integer n but also a random
integer a and do a random test in the
same sort of way